hi everybody my name is Greg and I'm one
of the designers on staff at posit and
I'm the person in the room that's
typically keeping an eye on brand design
guidelines like how things look and how
they feel and uh here are some brands
that I've worked with in the past
clients that I've had or places that
I've worked so as a graphic designer in
a room full of data scientists which
seems Preposterous cuz I'm your biggest
fan um I just want to say what do I want
I want designed for you to be an
afterthought people in this room are
literally like curing cancer and ending
world hunger you don't need someone like
me in the room saying cool cool cool
cool cool cool but is that the right
blue it's just not it doesn't really fit
and the way to do that is to create a
reusable Uh custom Cordo HTML theme now
Cordo HTML themes are a way that you can
customize a
website uh uh coming up manuscripts
books you can do stuff very quickly very
powerfully using these themes here's one
that I kind of put together real quick
using posits brand so let me give you a
little bit of background here on how
Cordo thinks about uh HTML themes it has
a base of bootstrap five and bootstrap
five is a very helpful kind of default
place to start a good foundation it's
going to decide fonts and colors for you
so you don't have to you can just get
your data analyses out there but maybe
you work for a company that says you
know we kind of want to use our fonts we
kind of want to use our colors or I
don't know maybe you just want to do
this for fun I don't know how you live
your life so here's how you do it it's
very simple CTO makes this very simple
you wire up uh uh you create and wire up
a theme. scss file I you can call it
whatever you want you just put it here
and and and make an scss file so right
here I put it in the cordoy which is
like the global settings for uh a Cordo
project but you could also put it in the
front matter of any qmd or there's a few
other places you can put it so here is a
reveal JS presentation that I've made
that's what I'm showing you now and I've
declared that the theme is going to be
theme. scss and that's where all of the
uh settings are if this project also is
going to become a website You' do it
this way you'd go HTML you declare the
theme and I want to show you this you
can actually set uh uh a light theme and
a dark theme and just by example under
dark I showed you how you can use many
different layers of things if you want
here so I've I've started with default
which is bootstrap 5 and then I've added
on the cosmos boot Swatch theme but
there a couple things I kind of wanted
to tweak there so I've also added on my
own dark theme. scss and just with a
comma in between Cordo we understand
what you're doing
there all right so here now that you've
wired it up here's the one file you need
to make it's a an scss file now there
are a lot of different things you can do
in this file I'm just going to talk
about two the first is scss SAS and in
general that's going to be one uh
variable that controls a lot of things
like I want this font to be everywhere
um and then also I want to talk a little
bit about CSS which you know in general
tends to control just one or a few
things like when you hover on a red
button I'd like the hover color to be
slightly different that kind of thing
all right so here is the scss file
here's how you set it up in the top part
we put this comment scss defaults and
then under that I'm going to put my SAS
variables and I'll show you what those
are in a second and then down below here
I've got the SS scss rules that's where
I'm going to put some CSS variables so
something I really want you to pay
attention to here is before you put the
SAS variables in or the CSS you need to
put that comment there for Cordo to pick
up uh what you're putting down okay so
like uh you need to have at least one of
those comments in there for Cordo to
understand what you're going for here
all right so what are the variables well
Cordo itself and all these links will be
in a repo at the end Cordo itself has
some very highlevel really powerful SAS
variables that are honestly going to get
you pretty far um but maybe you have
kind of like a a personnic brand that
needs to get a little bit more um detail
you can actually there's a big bench
behind that of bootstrap variables
there's actually like four over 1,400
bootstrap variables that'll let you
really fine-tune what you're doing and
the hope is once you've got these
changes to these variables uh in your
scss uh theme you'll never have to touch
them again when you're making this stuff
that's it's reusable now this is a
reveal JS presentation and that also has
oh wait one thing I want to tell you I
often don't go to that GitHub repo I go
to uh Carson s's BS lib package page
because it it lets you lets you filter
down like I want to see fonts don't show
me everything else I just want to see
fonts please I use this all the time
it's really helpful all right so this is
a revealed JS power uh presentation and
uh they also have some kind of uh
presentation variables that you can use
and if you're not making a presentation
it's okay that those variables are in
there it'll ignore them and if you are
making a presentation Corda will grab
them so it knows what to do with those
all right so that is my thing um if you
grab those variables you put them in a
theme the ones that you want to change
uh you'll be able to use them for
websites books uh manuscripts or in the
pre-release and PowerPoint presentations
if you have any questions you can email
me gregos it.co and uh links that I
showed there and how to geted started
are at this bitly link thank you so
[Applause]
much